you gotta have a plan everybody's got a
dream
everybody's got a goal what's the plan
and your plan has got to have something
I call the c5 complex your plan has got
to be clear concise compelling
consistent and committed you've got to
have a plan and when you're trying to do
something that you are truly passionate
about there is no plan B okay Plan B
sucks all right okay
so it's as simple as that you got to
have a plan I mean think about that for
a second three examples Michael Jordan
won six NBA championships with the
Chicago Bulls because he was committed
to plan a not Plan B Oprah Winfrey
became the queen of all media because
she was committed to plan eight not plan
B whatever your politics are Barack
Obama is sitting in the White House
because he was committed to plan a not
Plan B okay Plan B sucks always have a
plan B so remember and this is all
census data the average multimillionaire
in the US has seven different sources of
income so that means they have Plan B's
all the time so there's never a question
like okay if that was not working like I
had a business that I invested in a lot
of money recently and it wasn't working
but I have Plan B's I have like the
seven other Plan B's so I'm able to say
okay this is bringing me down every time
I talk to you guys I'm not gonna talk to
you anymore unless you have something
good to say to me and I could drop big
they could kick and scream but you put
all this money in I'm like okay I'm done
with that I have Plan B's so all the
time think about how many Plan B's
notice when I had a job at HBO I had a
plan B I had a cut before I left my job
at HBO I had my company running on the
side for 18 months before I left
full-time I had a dozen employees at my
company so always have the plan B's and
then it's easy to leave early in every
situation now again you don't have Plan
B's and relationships there's other
things
there you have to be careful of but you
know that's another talk my intention
with this video was to spread
understanding not fighting I want you to
see that it's not one point of view or
the other you can pull and learn from
both especially the one that you don't
immediately resonate with embrace the
genius of the end